Imagine that I am holding a piece of chromosome
2 right here and the part that I am
holding contains the lactase gene going of to my
left. The promoter region would be right here next to
the lactase gene ready to start transcription and turn
it on or off, and the mutation that controls lactase
expression. All the way down there where Lauren is
20,000 letters away is the mutation we've been talking about.
>> I feel so far away from this gene. How in the world could
it be affecting it?
>> I don't know. That's a really good
question. Why don't you think about it. How do
you think a letter, a change so far away
could affect transcription 20,000 letters away at the promoter.